mob randomly attacks couple walking in
Chicago they said they were going to
kill us so it quite literally is an
interracial couple apparently minding
their own business when they were
violently attacked by omob
they say they were randomly attacked
walking in downtown Chicago amid the
teen takeover Ashley and DJ said on
Tuesday they had been looking for a spot
to get food so tonight when they found
themselves trying to navigate a large
crowd people in the crowd pushed the
couple and when DJ stood up to them a
fight fighting broke out as soon as they
pushed me I told DJ I said they just
shoved me and he asked them he was like
yo don't shove her who shoved her and as
soon as he said that everything went
crazy they said they were they were
going to kill us the mob pushed Ashley
to the ground and immediately turned on
DJ to beat him they robbed the couple
stealing their shoes phones and a pair
of glasses and Apple watch and a hat
video the attack during the violent teen
takeover of the city went viral oh okay
so it was a a mob of young black
teenagers mercilessly beating an
interracial couple what is this teen
takeover thing uh it can like four
consecutive nights of large groups of
teenagers in Chicago just rampaging
through the city setting fires and
smashing Windows attacking people I
think they tried breaking into the Art
Institute and got shot yeah a couple
kids got shot I don't know about getting
shot but they were trying to break in
the Art Institute in their work was
fired a couple kids did get shot yeah uh
two of them and I thought it was because
they were trying to break it I'm not
sure
well you don't want teenagers
controlling your Society I'll tell you
that
well thanks Ian yeah you know this is
perhaps a racially motivated attack it's
not been described that way but oh no it
definitely is so to go to your point
about the double standard
we don't know what the motivations were
in Kansas City but there's an assumption
it had to be racial we have pretty good
evidence it might have been racial in
Chicago but we don't talk about that
well it's clearly we can talk about it
but it's okay right yeah it was clearly
a racist mob attacking this interracial
couple because you know you can talk
about it but just don't talk about it
too much because then you're a racist
and it's okay the thing that offended me
the most about what the mayor-elect said
and others said was that these kids had
no other choice for entertainment on a
weekend because they come from deprived
backgrounds and they are impoverished or
whatever which is no opportunities no
opportunities right for recreation I
guess the parks were closed or something
I mean it's Chicago has so much to do
and these kids have phones and they have
cars and
you know maybe they're
they have some other frustrations and
challenges but it is it's awful it is
excused like that it is exhausting to
hear such obvious
shove down your throat all the
time to hear comments like that it is
just yeah I I can't describe it as
anything other than just exhausting they
don't have anything to do so they have
to ransack on the city give me a the
light the likelihood that these people
voted for this is like 99 yeah this is
not a young conservative couple sorry
they probably either don't vote or vote
Democrat so I just like yeah we don't
want violent mobs to break out but
there's I'm torn right like if Phil if
you voted
for the government to I don't know
um
give you a free car and then the
government gave you a free car back oh
wow look at that you know you voted and
got a car like who's paying for it I
have questions about like where it's
coming from if you voted for the
government to take your paycheck from
you and then they did I'd be like well
congratulations like you asked him to do
it they did you know it's like if I ask
a guy take the garbage out and he does
it why would I be upset about it I don't
like the metaphor if I voted for them
and they're perpetuating the the
violence so I'm responsible because I
voted for you voted for Obama I voted
for Obama and then I realized it was a
mistake and then I didn't vote for him
with your argument they'd be like well
you're it's because of you that 2008 to
12 happened yeah you're responsible
that's a fact it is you killed those
kids like that's what yes my support for
Barack Obama and what pissed me off and
made me so extremely angry with
Democrats was that yes I gave Obama the
support he needed to murder
children and that pisses me off yes
technically yeah yes I did but you
didn't do that with that intention of
course not it doesn't matter if I give
someone a brick and then they say hey
give me that breakfast say okay and then
they start hitting something I'm gonna
be like yo I shouldn't have given in
that break got Authority you gave me
Authority but any president would have
had that Authority that's the reason
that I feel terrible about voting for
Bush because of the war in Iraq like
that's why people like change their
votes they're like they vote for someone
because they're hoping for something the
person they voted for gives them a pile
of because that's what they do and
then people like well I don't want to
vote for them anymore that's that's just
the normal thing that people that's why
people are so sick of the government
after that I didn't vote in 2012 or 2016
because I was like I don't want to be
responsible for what these
do and then Donald Trump did a bunch of
really great things with the economy and
really great things with foreign policy
to the point where I said this guy needs
another term I mean the foreign policy
stuff was so good that I was finally
like okay this guy actually did these
things he also set up a clandestine
drone Network where he gave his generals
authority to bomb whoever they want in
secret that's right but I look at what
he did as he was working more to pull
the us out of what other people started
and I can certainly recognize with that
comes the collateral damage that George
W bush created I don't even I don't even
necessarily want to blame Barack Obama
for for starting the wars that George W
Bush started I'm with you there but he
did sign off on these things Donald
Trump did as well and I think he should
be held responsible however the reason I
like what Donald Trump was doing was
that he was actively pulling it all back
can I ask you something about the
foreign policy issues because you were
there
documenting the Occupy Wall Street
movement the anti-war movement was a big
part of the motivation for Obama's
victory in 2008 whether he said so
explicitly or not people had the idea
this guy was going to get us out of
Bush's Wars and that kind of thing Along
Comes Donald Trump doesn't go to war
four years of Peace Putin doesn't invade
anybody
and Abraham Abraham Accords and the left
brain negotiation nobody gives him I
mean I shouldn't say nobody there's
Glenn green wall there's a few questions
there's a few other people give him
credit but the left for whom this was
the issue or so I thought decided that
they had to get rid of trump and now
we've got Biden risking on every front
yeah pro war as they come so I mean what
happens to the anti-war movement where
is the left with this did they just
forget about it do people Mumble and
walk away what happens I feel I can't be
part of that making it I'm part of that
movement I feel like it is Unstoppable
that the military-industrial complex
controls our country and that it's we're
just in a military autocracy
and and stop full stop I don't know what
else to do I used to dismiss that view
but when I see
just observing the FBI interference and
the Intel leaks and the Russia collusion
plot and how there was the hunter Biden
Russian disinformation letter and this
collusion between elements of our
intelligence community and the
Democratic party I can't dismiss that
anymore I feel like well we have this
democracy but it's as much as they allow
us to have and you can't elect the wrong
candidate otherwise as Chuck Schumer
warned they will get at you a hundred
different ways and just pull it out from
under you which is what they did
but I mean but how do you look at that
if you're on the left how do you look at
that and say wait a minute I don't like
Trump and I can even think he's a racist
but I can't go along with what they're
doing the left doesn't have principles
there there is no there is no moral
framework that exists among the left in
fact I think what makes the left
distinct is a clear lack of a moral
framework that's it but I have friends
and relatives who are leftists and they
believe these things with good
intentions they believe they have a
moral framework I can't say to them well
you disagree with me because you have no
morals but they don't right so someone's
arguments are different from what they
actually do so like
they have no legitimate reason for
supporting war with Ukraine none there's
no more there's no moral basis for that
well it's the fear that he's gonna go
from country to Country to Country and
this is the first one like Hitler went
into Poland but there there there's no
unless you outright say like I think the
United States should take over the world
should be actively you know et cetera et
cetera Empire nation building whatever
you can't be on the left opposing George
W bush opposing expansion of war and
then be supporting Ukraine that proves
you have no moral framework other than
there is no truth but Power lately I've
been like well I've stopped taking the
the view of hey stop doing the war quit
that I no longer do that anymore now I'm
like how can we redivert resources so
that the military-industrial complex can
remain super profitable yeah and we can
Ally with Russia and make more money for
everybody like there's got to be a new
not just stop and don't that won't work
anymore it's right it's moving so I I'm
sorry I lost what I was saying because
yeah
well you know what just sorry I have a
different I'm not anti-war I'm my point
real quick I was I wanted to see what
you hear what you had to say my point
was the left has no moral framework
because they say we oppose George W bush
yeah I feel like I feel like I
understand what you're saying I feel
like the reason that they're oh I think
that the left is okay with global
government with a global government
because the left is it like the the left
is where communism comes from and that's
and you don't get real communism unless
you have like Global communism so I
don't think that the the left isn't okay
with that kind of stuff and I do think
that the left is okay with expansive
governments and stuff like that because
that's how you end up with a global guy
do you think the average
but I don't think that I don't think
that it makes I understand what you're
saying when they when you say that
doesn't make sense for this particular
war in general do you think the average
Democrat voter supports communism no I
think the average Democrat voter is the
is the default leftist which shows
there's no moral framework yes you can
say that some elements of the left are
communist yeah but when the majority of
their voter base doesn't know or care or
pay attention yeah there's just no moral
framework that's the default that's the
difference between leftists and
Democrats is that you can vote for the
Democratic candidate and be completely
politically ignorant that then you're
not a leftist but if you're politically
active and you're into that kind of
thing you become on the left it's the
activation of political ideology that
puts you in a right or left concept
whether you're a Republican or Democrat
well you might just be completely
apolitical Andrew Breitbart called it
the default liberal I believe that's
that was the saying that's that's that's
what I think about the corporate press I
think he's I think Breitbart was was
totally on it right with that the
Democrats of the party of the nice
voters so yeah thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time